and uh she will talk about
deliberative coalition formation to
change the status quo
um i shall be uh following the the chat
so if you have questions during the talk
uh you can write uh something there and
then i can interrupt edith and
get you to ask your question okay eat it
the floor is yours
yeah thanks rupak for the introduction
thanks for having me here
i'm not sure if this talk is a
particularly great fit for this seminar
series
but at least in my defense i can say
that
okay this is a token voting but it
doesn't require
any background in voting theory or game
theory
it's pretty much from the first
principles
so i hope it will be well both
interesting and accessible
okay so let me start with
a little bit of background in political
science so
in political science one of the major
topics that is being studied
is how political parties form collisions
in order to cover and the popular model
there is a spatial model
so the setup is typically that we think
of political parties as
agents or players in the game and these
parties
either have positions principal
positions
in a multi-dimensional proposal space or
maybe more cynically
they decide which positions to adopt
right so
when when i'm talking about proposal
space i'm thinking
things like okay so what this is
what sort of position do they support on
the various controversial
issues whatever which fraction of the
budget
should be spent on military spending
uh whether whether abortions should be
kind of allowed or prohibited or some
intermediate position
right so usually uh kind of political
positions
so can be described by a smallish number
of dimensions
so you can think of each party as taking
a position on each of these
issues right and that determines the
support of each
party so voters typically also have
their positions and they tend to pay for
parties that are similar to them
so what happens is parties either
naturally have dispositions or they
adopt these positions and
then parties have their supporters and
they aim to form a winning coalition to
cover
right so winning coalition would be one
that is large enough
to have the mandate to govern so if you
think about
parties in the parliament so it would be
poverties that constitute at least half
of the parliament members
or something like that okay so then this
part is former coalition
so this coalition also has to adopt some
sort of position in the issue space
which you can think of as being some
kind of median
of the positions of individual uh
coalition members
and the questions one can then ask is so
which coalitions are going for
are going to form which positions are
they going to adopt
will this be the best so which processes
will lead to efficient coalition
information
so that the most popular the most
supported position
is actually supported by a coalitional
disposition
right and of course this is a major
topic in political science there is very
substantial literature
so it goes back to 1920s to the famous
work of hoteling
so there's plenty of and work on that as
well okay so that's the background now
let me position
what we do in this paper against this
spectrum so
like in this classic look we assume that
there's a proposal space
so it's a metric space can be a finite
or infinite subset of
rd for instance
so these are proposals that can be
adopted by parties and by the voters
and each agent has an ideal point in
this proposal space
which is her opinion so for instance
which fraction of the budget should be
spent on education
so whether there should be universal
mass mandate or not or something
intermediate
this sort of thing okay
in addition to that and this is fairly
unusual for the literature
there's a special point which is the
current situation the status quo
right so the status quo is a specific
point so we can think of it as a zero
point
and what agents are interested in
figuring out
is whether the status quo is the best
they can do
or if there is at least half of the
agent majority of agents
that can form a coalition around some
outcome that is different from the
status quo
right so if there is a way to move away
from the status quo
uh in a way that would be approved by
the majority
okay and what we assume about our agents
is that their highest priority
is to understand if there is any change
from the status quo that there would be
majority supported
and they're very open to the compromise
right so they don't
open being open to compromise
effectively means
that they would be happy with building a
large collision
around a position that is maybe just
slightly better for them than the status
quo
rather than having a small coalition
closer to the ideal point
okay so more dramatically so what we
have in mind is
agents with approval preferences
okay so here's a picture so here's an
image of what we want to do
so we have a reality the status quo with
the point r
and so here's a couple of voltages we
one and three
so for each voter this is uh there's a
space of all proposals
that they would prefer to this they
would prefer to the status quo
and this is everything that is closer to
them than the status quo
so agent v1 would prefer everything
inside of this circle
to the status quo agent v2 would prefer
everything inside her circle to the
status quo
so if you look at the intersection so
these are positions they could both
adopt that would that both of them would
prefer to the status quo
so for any of the points in there if
there is any proposal
kind of in the intersection of these two
circles they could adopt that proposal
and form a coalition around it
which would be supported by the books
okay and we'll try to make it slightly
more formal what it means for agents to
be open to compromise later on so for
now let me just say that
agents preference are fundamentally
approval preferences
so they prove everything that is better
for them than the status quo
everything within their circle but they
don't distinguish among different things
instead
in that circle right so we won't we are
not going to say that agent one
prefers the center of the circle to the
to the periphery
right and neither does agent two right
so they're just happy with any change
and they're willing to compromise
willing to
adopt a point somewhere within their
circle that can
get a lot of support from other audience
okay so another way to think about it
geometrically is in terms of which
proposals can that can get support
right so here's this proposal a right so
it sits inside the circle of agent one
so agent one supports it it sits outside
of the circle of agent two
so agent two does not support it so
where do where do we find agents that
support a
well geometrically it's very it's very
simple to see
so we connect a and r right and then
draw a perpendiculars in the middle of
that segment
and all agents that sent above this line
so they're all closer to eight and or
so they can potentially form a collision
around a and all
agents on the other side refer r to a so
there's no way they can support
a right so we'll be kind of reasoning in
terms of the circles and lines in both
followings
okay so let's do an example right so
let's talk about
about the pandemic response so i'm
thinking of pandemic response
as operating on two major axes
so one is what is open and what is
closed right and that can range from
only keeping the essential shops open so
let's say that this is the minimum
amount of openness that the society
needs to function and up to
say open nightclubs that are knee
that are both inessential and
potentially
kind of a very that bad for spreading of
it right so this is my
openness axis right and there's another
axis which is masking axis
and that ranges from no masks whatsoever
no mask mandate of any kind to masks
uh everywhere including on the streets
and in the parks
and on the beaches kind of everywhere
okay so let's say so suppose
guys i'm not sure if i guess they're all
geographically distributed
so let's think of the point or that
would be for instance the uk
in december which would be somewhere
halfway between
these two extremes on both axes right so
there would be things that are
that were open beyond essential shops
but certainly night clubs
and large group activities would not be
open right and there were requirements
to wear masks on the buses
and in the shops but in the uk there was
never
a requirement to their mask industry
right so that would be the current
reality
right okay so this is my masking access
right so so some of these things i
ordered somewhat arbitrarily
but generally sex is supposed to go from
no masking to universal masking
right and this is my openness
and let's say we have voters who have
different positions with regard to these
two axes
so for instance voter one is heavily
opposed to any kind of mask monday
but also they don't want things to be
broadly right so they insist on no mask
monday but they find these only
take-away food establishments being open
in the central shops and not beyond that
right then kind of on the other extreme
we have agents who
wants everything to be open but also
insists on universal nasties
right then kind of all sorts of various
positions so let's try to think
kind of how these agents can agree on
majority to support the change from the
status quo
but there are several possible ways to
agree on something that is different
from the status quo
so for instance let's look at this
horizontal line right agents who sit
above that line and there is a majority
of agents above this line
right they can agree on a proposal that
sits for instance they can agree on the
proposal
that keeping the same level of masking
but
opening cafes for eating them right so
all of them would be closer to this
point than they otherwise
meaning they can form a majority
collision that says
well let's keep the same level of
masking but little bit more openness
and they get majority support for that
and here's another option
right agents v3 v4 and vm5 and to the
right of this line
right so they can form a majority
collision that aren't used
for the same level of openness but a
slightly higher level of masking
right and the largest kind of shandy can
plausibly form
so you can convince yourself that you
know there's no weight we can
all five agents can agree on a change
from status quo
right so geometrically if you draw all
the five circles
kind of the centers at one two three and
four three four five
there won't be a common point of
intersection but we can form a collision
of four agents
so for instance agents two three four
and five
can agree on a point that would sit well
here somewhere
right which would argue for a little bit
more masking and a little bit more
openness
right and potentially there could also
be another coalition involving
one two three and four that would argue
for a little bit less masking and a
little bit more openness
right so that would be kind of the most
supported proposals
right so they're different most
supported proposals
uh and they're different collections
supporting them but we can get
four agents to support change from the
status
okay so what kind of clinician
information process do i have in mind
so the way i'm thinking about the
coalition
is a set of agents plus the position
that they support
right so this is the object that i'm
going to call the deliberative condition
right and deliberative collision can
only form if
all agents in the collection prefer the
proposal
put forward by that condition to the
status quo so for instance in the
previous slide
so i put four mechanism
around opening cafes for eating in
in the current level of masking which
would consist of v2
v3 and v4 right and the connection
structure now would be a partition of
agents into these deliberative
conditions
right so each agent sits in exactly one
punch right and each coalition has a
proposal that it supports
right and then i'm thinking of this as
being a dynamic process
so the agents start with some collision
structure so
possibly with each agent just being in a
single templation
and arguing for his own his or her own
ideal point
right and then agents slowly start
forming coalitions
potentially changing their opinions so
what kind of transitions do we have in
mind
well the simplest kind of transition
would be we could look at would be
single agent deviations an agent moves
from the connection she's currently in
to a different condition right so we
could also think of position changes a
collision currently supports a proposal
in the changes to supporting a different
proposal or perhaps two coalitions can
merge
right and decide on a new proposal to
support
or even more generally two coalitions
can merge
but maybe leave some members of each
collision behind
if these members don't support the new
problems so what can happen is c
is that c p and c prime p prime
can join together around some new
proposal p star
but not everyone in c and not everyone
in c prime would support that you
proposed
right so these are the type of
transitions we'd like to reason about
right so ideally we'd like to consider
transitions that remove a limited number
of conditions
right because large it's very difficult
to hold negotiations among large number
of collisions
right so in particular i would like to
understand for the most of the token
focus on transitions that only involve
two coalitions at the time and
the goal would be to understand what
collision structures connect
okay so i mentioned that our agents are
compromising
right so the compromise seeking and the
goal is to build a large collision to
move away from the status quo
so we think of agents of doing that
myopic
so we we say that agents favor larger
coalitions
so that the transition is only feasible
if it leads to the formation of a larger
condition
right so in that sense for instance if i
have two agents
if i have two collisions one collision
is of size three and the other one is
equal
is explanation of size five then an
agent from a smaller coalition can move
to the larger condition
right because then the moving agent
would move from a coalition that used
that was size 3 and the new coalition
would be size 6
but not vice versa later agents who are
now in condition of size 5 wouldn't move
to a condition that is now of size 3.
on the other hand so it may happen that
if we have two collisions of size 4
an agent from the first collision of
size 4 would move to the second
collision of size 4
because now that collision would be of
size for you right so agents favor
larger coalitions
right so they're myopically trying to
build the majority supported collisions
can change away from the status quo
right so to give you some information
from that if you notice the list of my
courses on that project
right so i had two israeli courses ud
shapiro and nimrod talmud
right so if you've been following
israeli politics a little bit
right so there's currently some
coalition building in israel
to displace their current leader
benjamin netanyahu
right and kind of this is the sort of
inspiration
right so pretty pretty much everyone on
the left in israeli politics
would be willing to form a coalition
that changes away from the status quo
they don't insist
kind of on any particular kind of change
as long as it's
in the right direction but they do want
to achieve change
right so this is the kind of setting you
want to formalize
okay so here so this is our research
question
so with this compromise seeking agents
which types of transitions
guarantee emergence of a coalition
around
one of the most supportive outcomes
right so this is what we are going to
call success right so agents have these
dynamics where they
split where they merge where they move
from one collision to another
right and the eventual goal as a group
is to identify one of the most supported
outcomes and build the
right so what kind of transitions allow
them to achieve this goal
right and of course the answer may
depend on the metric space
and in what follows we're going to see
how it actually depends on the metric
space
right and there's a secondary question
head over in our computer scientist hats
we asked if this convergence can be
achieved after binomial many transitions
okay so i'm afraid this was quite handy
wavy
so let me try to start making it a
little bit more full
okay so why did you find what what
is a deliberative collision and
deliberative collision structure
so let me now talk a little bit more
formally about transitions
okay so single agent transitions are of
this form
so we have the coalition structure right
in this collection structure have
appeared collisions
agents in collision c support b agents
in collision c
prime support between right and from
there i can
move it to collisions
c union a and collisions c prime
minus a right so effectively this means
that agent a
who used to be in collision c prime
moves the collision c
okay and this transition can only happen
if collision c was at least as large as
collision c
prime so agent a myopically increases
the size of her condition
and agent a approves b right so what
happens here is agent a
looks at proposals of other collections
identifies a proposal that she approves
right and observes that if she were to
join this other coalition
she would be in a larger coalition than
she is
in currently right and then she decides
to move
so this is a single agent transition a
follow transition
is a transition where we have two
coalitions and they merge
behind the proposal of one of these
conditions
right so c supported b c prime supported
b prime and now c and c prime merge and
they support the proposal uh supported
by c
and the slightly okay so when can this
happen this can happen if
all agents who are in collision c prime
are happy to be in a collision that
supports b right so this move can only
happen
uh if uh all agents in this new
coalition would actually support its
verbose
okay and of course so uh this collision
increa this collection is beneficial for
agents in c prime
because the size of the new collision is
bigger than the original collision
so they're happy to move because they
approved the new proposal and this
results in a big attachment
a slightly more general type of
transition is merge transition
so it's kind of it's almost the same as
follow transition
except we allow the agents to adopt a
new proposal
right so intuitively this new proposal p
star may be some sort of compromise
between p
and p star right and again we don't have
to worry about collision sizes because
the merge
increases the collision size by
definition
and again so it can only happen if all
members of both collisions approve this
new proposal please start
okay so finally our most general type of
transition
is what we call compromise transitions
right so those are slightly more
complicated
so again we start with two collisions
one supporting p
another supporting p star so they're
going to move to a new proposal
piece one supports p the other supports
p prime
and they're going to move to a new
proposal p star
right but not everyone in c and not
everyone in c prime is going to move to
this new purpose
right so what's going to happen is in c
there's some subset
c p prime who supports this new proposal
p star
in c prime there is also a subset c
prime t
star apologies for the notation who
support this new proposal p
star right so the agents from both
conditions who support p
star are going to move to p star and
they may leave some agents behind in the
local in their old coalitions
who would still support b and who would
still support people
and for this move to happen well the
agents who move
have to support this new proposal b star
and
also the collision that they form should
be bigger than any of the original
conditions
right so they break away from the old
collision partners
to build a bigger collision around the
proposal they all approve
well so you can see that the theme here
is that the new collision
should be bigger than the old collision
in
in any case the coalition that forms is
such that all members of that coalition
approve its proposal
right so these are the four types of
transitions we are going to consider
questions at this point complaints
hi uh yeah i have a question so
uh why don't agents
do at least some local optimization so
for example in the first transition
just pick the one with largest
size of whose proposal you approve
right yeah so we could cons we could
consider that as well
uh yeah so that would that would make
sense as well so single
yes so this is kind of better is
sponsored and best response type of
dynamics
uh it's i think
many of our results would hold for that
case as well
so you can also say that in case of
follow transitions right say if there
are several mergers available they
should go for the largest available
merge
right so i think yeah so that would be a
reasonable variant to be considered
but we kind of conceptualize our agents
as maybe having some secondary
considerations
beyond just maximizing the size
so this just gives them more freedom
right so if you can prove convergence
results in this more permissive
framework
right so i think that right so if you
say that any sequence of single agent
transitions as defined here
is actually good right so that's a
strong result
right so but certainly what you propose
would also make sense
just not only consider it in the paper
and
so maybe as we go through the proofs i
can try to think on the fly
if it would work for this gen for this
definition as well but i'm not sure
okay thanks yeah it is if i may can you
explain please a little bit more
the condition that cardinality of c is
bigger or equal than the cardinality of
c
prime in the single agent transition
this condition prevents
small coalitions from getting bigger it
kind of favors bigger coalitions
right yeah so it favors bigger
coalitions and
for one thing it's important for
convergence
right so it helps that the process won't
cycle so we'll prove that formally in a
second but maybe it's obvious to you
right but remember our agents want
to build a majority coalition right and
this is just saying they're doing it
myopic
they're not smart enough to figure out
that maybe some sequence of these
transitions will help eventually
right so they just say okay if i can be
in a bigger collection in the next step
right so this is something i'm going to
pay for right so the smallest collection
can never grow
the second smallest coalition can still
grow because agents from these small
establishments can join it
yes it is a model that
there is getting richer so to speak as
already
yes sir it's getting richer but yes i
think it's
uh yeah so we don't have any kind of
splits here or moves to smaller
coalitions
but i think if our agents are in the
business of identifying
kind of a group that can actually
achieve change it's not unreasonable for
them to optimize that every step to try
to get
to try to build a bigger group thank you
thank you
okay so on the other hand agents i would
say that our agents are very nice to
each other because they're willing to
compromise
right so they're willing to adopt
proposals that are different
from their optimal proposals they're
willing to adopt
anything that they prefer to the status
quo right so this thing
p star here can be kind of quite
far so so it may be the case that all
agents in c are pretty tightly clustered
on b all agents in c prime are pretty
pretty closely clustered around p prime
yet they may be willing to adopt p star
if it brings more people on board
right so they're nice in that sense okay
so let's there is another question um
daniel
i mean you can just unmute yourself and
ask questions
hi yeah can you guys hear me yeah
uh yeah so uh yeah i just had a quick
question about like the model
formulation
so it seems like so you're using this
like the metric space structure just to
determine what are like the sets of
positions that an agent would approve
right since like it doesn't matter it's
sort of the distance
beyond the distance from like the status
quo
so i guess like what is the reason for
like would it be equivalent to just like
define a
set of approval sets for each agent
rather than having like this metric
space
uh so you will see this in the results
right so the results will be different
depending on the type of the metric
space they live in
right so the basically the story will be
that if everyone lives in a simple
metric space these approvals are induced
by a very simple kind of metric then
simple transitions
guarantee successful deliberation right
and if the metric space is more complex
then you need
a richer kind of transitions right so in
that sense it's
useful
okay got it thank you okay so understand
that this is vague so hopefully we'll
see some examples we'll see some results
this will be helpful
okay so let's look for instance at this
example so we have the reality the
status quo in the center
right so think of it as a metric in rd
right so we have
a bunch of proposals a a prime
b b c so the proposals are in blue the
agents are in red
and this is the current collision
structure so let's say
so we have v1 v2 and v3 forming a
collision around a
v4 v5 and v6 forming a cholesterol
b and v7 forming a singlet and polish
now and see
right and let's say that these are the
only proposals that are available
so in particular agents are unable to
articulate a proposal
that would exactly correspond to their
position right so there is no proposal
that sits exactly at v7
right so c is the closest proposal
to agent seven that agent seven can
actually describe in words
okay i think you can see that these
collisions actually
reasonable deliberative connections in
the sense that
v one is closer to a than trace to r
right and v two is closer to eight than
three star
and v three is closer to eight and three
star right so
this is v3 va this is v3 br
so every agent approves the proposal
that the collection puts forward
okay so what can we say about so it is a
successful outcome of deliberation
right so we have two collections of
sites three one collision of size
one so seven agents all together
so majority supported would mean to have
an outcome supported by four agents
can we possibly have a collision of size
four here
okay so what's your sense of things
can anyone identify proposals that could
be supported by four agents
p p good right so proposal p
v two v three v four v five could form
potentially this majority
right so if they were not limited by my
stupid transitionals
right then if they could just do
whatever they like they could actually
form that collision
right so now let's look at our
transition rules and see which
transition rules allow them to do that
and which transition rules don't okay
so the first observation is that here
they have no single agent
incisions right so there's no agent that
can move from the collision
to any other of the any other existing
connections
right so for instance if you look at
agent v4
uh maybe v4 would want to move to this
paralysis that supports a
right so at least so v4 might might
consider that but now v4 is too far from
a
right so the distance between v4 and a
is bigger than the distance between v4
and r
so for v4 it's not a feasible move right
and
of course similarly for the agents here
right so v7
can't move to this collision because b
is too far so v7 can't move to this
condition because a is too far
okay so what the first collision can
close if they do it
it can change its position so we can
allow a transition like that so it
so this coalition can change its
position from a to a prime
right and then all agents in that
collision would still support it
right so that's possible right and then
maybe v4
after that happens v4 would be able to
join that connection
okay okay so that's one possibility so
we're not going to talk
much about this change the position
collisions in this talk but this is
certainly a possibility here
so another thing to note is that there
are no merge transitions here
no two collisions can merge right so for
instance these two large collisions
this there isn't any point in this among
my proposal points that they could merge
around
right so for instance it's not the case
that they can all merge around b
because b 1 and v 6 don't like b they're
closer to r than they are to b
so merge transitions are not possible
right
so p is majority supported and but what
we have
sorry so what we have is we could
potentially have a compromised
transition
around p so the compromise would involve
these
these two collisions the collisional b
so two agents from each collision would
abandon the existing coalition
and form a parish and joint layout so
that would be a compromise transition
it would be a valid compromise
transition because all these four guys
approved b
and it would be a collision of size four
which would be an improvement for each
of them
okay so the question i want to ask is in
what
space is what kind of transitions
guarantee success
okay and for single agent transition so
the answer is kind of very negative
in single single legion transition may
fail to succeed
even in one dimension right and this is
an easy way to see that
so let's look at this metric space uh
baby have
same proposals a b c you have a
collection and a
collection on b collection on c and
it's easy to see here that b is actually
supported by the majority right so
majority of voters prefer
b to the status quo to the reality right
but if these are the current conditions
right so single agent transitions both
are not going to get us there so why is
that the case
well uh an agent who is currently
sitting in a collection that supports c
would not move to b because he is
currently in coalition of size three
and if he moves he would be in a
coalition of size three again
so not an improvement right so not worth
it to him
right and the asians who sit around
being they can't
move to the conditions that supports
right because on the other hand of
course that would put them in a bigger
collection
but that proposal is too radical for
them right so they're closer to our
than to the proposal of that coalition
right so they wouldn't want to move
right so single agent transitions are
not going to bring about
a majority collision somewhere to the
left or false
right so single agent transitions are
not very interesting in that regard
on the other hand if we are just sitting
in one dimension
it's enough to consider follow
transitions right so remember follow
transitions have been two collisions
merge and they merge around the proposal
of one of these punishments
so in particular in these examples the
two collisions on the right so the
collision around c
and collision round b they could merge
around b
right so these asians as a group can
move to the left
right so if they move as a group this
results in a collision of satisfying so
that makes them happy
putin's actually approved b right so b
is certainly much less
radical than the change they support but
it's still preferable to them compared
to the status quo
so it's happy to do that okay and in
general not just
not just in this example but in general
in one dimension follow transitions
converge
right and an easy way to see that is
first we can observe
that no collision can possibly span zero
have members both to the left of zero
and to the right of zero
right because there is no proposal that
can be supported
both by the left wing guys and by the
right-wing guys
right so some of them would prefer
out of that proposal in any case right
so collections come in
two flavors the coalition's on the left
and coalitions on the right
like that if we have for instance two
positive collisions like in this picture
they could always merge around the less
radical proposition
right so in the end of our process if if
our process consists of follow
transitions only
uh so if we converge this means that we
have at most two conditions one positive
and one negative right and at least so
one of these collisions would have to be
a majority connection
right so one of these collisions would
have to contain at least all of the
agents
right so in one dimension uh just follow
transitions are sufficient
convergence right and we can mix up
follow and single agent transitions
so we can allow both kinds of
transitions right and that won't break
this result
right because so the argument here
doesn't require follow transitions to be
exclusive if you have
any kind of alternating sequence of
following single agent transitions
so in any case if we converge we'll have
at most two coalitions and therefore one
of them
supports a majority supported proposal
okay any complaints about this proof
so far so good
okay good okay but now if we move if you
want to move beyond one dimensions we
find two dimensions
then single agent sensations and also
follow transition may fail to succeed
okay so this is a very simple example so
here they have two collisions one is a
coalition around a
another one is a cholesterol and b and
all these agents
uh would be very happy very happy to see
that b
that's all my red dots prefer p to r
but this proposal right so it's not the
case that agents on the left
uh approve b it's not the case that
agents on the right approve a
so they can't just follow each other so
the left collision can't
follow the right collision the right
collision can't follow the left
condition
right so if they were to form a
compromise it would have to be different
from the original tripod so they can
merge around b
but they can't merge around a or b right
so single agent and follow transitions
may be insufficient
okay so where where are they sufficient
so you can ask in what kind of metric
spaces are
merged transitions
are merge transition sufficient well if
you look at
trees
uh so you so if you look at trees as
geometric spaces
then just merge transition is actually
sufficient for success
right so when i talk about trees as
metallic spaces so this is the picture i
have in mind so i have a tree potential
weighted tree
each edge is associated with a distance
so proposals
are is a subset of vertices of this tree
each agent also sits at some vertex of
this stream
so distances are measured along this
tree right
and then so i ask uh if agents can
converge using
merge transitions right and then the
answer is yes right and the reason why
the answer is yes
is if there is a majority supported
proposal
then i claim that one of the children of
the root
would be a majority supported proposal
right because if you think about
this proposal b then everyone who sits
in the tree rooted at b actually prefers
p to r
right so all agents sitting in various
collisions
children of b right so any pair of these
collisions can have a merged transition
where they form a compromiser and b
right and then other collisions in that
circle we can
uh join them one by one right so if
and on the other hand it's clear that
agents who sit
in this subtree and agents who sit in
this subtly can't compromise
right so whatever is approved by agents
here is not approved by agents here
right so if there is a potential point
of compromise majority supported
compromise
it has to be in one of the children and
it's an easy way for
agents in the chapter to reach that
point by mergers
okay and also you can note that just
follow transitions are not enough you
genuinely need mergers
because for instance if at the beginning
you have a collision at a in the
collision at b
right so they can't accept each other's
proposals
right so the choices at a are too far
from b
so if you think of these edges as being
cuny distance then the distance to b
is four and the distance to the root is
three so the agents from here can't move
to here
the agents from here can't move to here
but what they can do is join forces at
least
so emerges are sufficient on trees
but on the other hand motors are not
sufficient in two dimensions
right so if you look at this picture
right and this is a modification of a
picture from a couple of slides before
uh so still here p is a majority
supported purpose
right so we have six agents all together
four of them
could potentially support me but
currently they're sitting in this left
collision and right collision
and to form a collision around b
[Music]
well they can't achieve it by merge
right because these two agents
agent at the bottom would veto the merge
they prefer r to b right so just
merge transitions wouldn't allow
the agents for proof p to get together
to be
right and to to form that known to be we
need
what remember we call the compromise
transition right the agents from both
coalitions who like b
actually uh form a collection of b right
so this illustrates why we need
compromise transitions
okay so how powerful are compromise
transitions
right and here's what i think is kind of
the most technical interesting result in
this paper
so my claim is if the proposal space is
rt
if any point in rd is a potential
proposal
then these two base compromises actually
sufficient
right so compromises among two
collisions
can help agents identify a majority
supported proposal
or just more broadly the most supported
troubles
any sequence of compromise okay so let
me make this claim more formal
so suppose we have a sequence of
compromise transitions right and then it
stops
because there are no more compromised
transitions available
i claim that at this point there is
a collision in my deliberative collision
structure whose supported proposal
is the one of the most supported
proposals
right and this holds for any dimension d
i'm going to prove it in
two dimensions so it will be slightly
hand-wavy but not too far
from the actual truth so i'll prove it
in two dimensional but the proof
actually generalizes it's just easier to
visualize it in two dimensions
okay so here's the proof idea so suppose
so i suppose i'm at this point when no
more compromises are available
right so now i'm asking now i'm looking
at my collision structure i ask how many
collisions are they
suppose i'm left with just two
collisions but none of them supports a
majority supported purpose
right and that's impossible because if i
have two collisions
they can always compromise if the so we
can take
we can look at this majority supported
the most popular proposal
we can take all agents from the first
coalition who support it and we can take
all agents from the
second partition who support it and we
can bring them together
into a coalition around that most
supported reposition
and that would be a valid compromise
transition right so they can't get stuck
without identifying that most supported
proposal
right so if i if i ended up these two
collisions
this means that one of them is actually
a coalition around
a most supportive proposal good okay so
now suppose i somehow
ended up with more than two collisions
three or more
yet none of them uh is a coalition
none of them is supporting a most
popular purpose
and i'm going to get a contradiction
right so suppose i have three or more
consciously
which in this case what i'm going to
argue is that
either there is a single agent deviation
in which some agent can
join one of the maximum size conscience
or else there are two colors that can
match
okay and kind of the first one is a
single agent deviation
the second one is a merge deviation both
can be
can be thought of as special cases of
confirmation transitions
okay so why is that the case well let's
look at my maximum size colors
right so in this picture my maximum size
collection it is collection of five
voters
who form a color strand some proposal a
so just dramatically let me draw a line
between a and
r and let me draw a
another line that is perpendicular to
this ar line and goes to its middle
okay so now by construction remember all
agents
in all ages in this collection around a
they all sit uh above that line
right so preferring a to r geometrically
means exactly being on one side of the
slide being closer to 8 and
1. right so this line nicely separates
my agents
okay good let me now move this line to r
okay so i've got my new line now going
through r
i don't know let me consider two cases
one
case is i have some agents who
sit above this line who sit on the same
side of this line as a does
so for now let me assume that no one
sits exactly on this line right and
later
i'll say what to do if that's not true
but suppose no one is sitting on the
line
right so first option is that some
agents not in this a collision
who still sit on the same side of this
line as a collisions
then here's what i'm going to do right
so this is my picture
i'm going to identify a new point a
prime
somewhere on this segment very very
close to r
so that when now i draw a new line
parallel to my original line
and through the middle of this a prime r
segment right so
then this line will still have all
these points on one side of it
and because i have a finite number of
points i can choose a prime close enough
to r
that this line would be very close to my
original line and still have all these
points on one side
i don't know this new line separates
uh all these agents from our right and
it goes to the middle of ri
r a prime and this means that all these
agents actually approve april
including this guy from the other
college right and now
i have a compromise move where this
large collision
and this one guy from the other
condition form a new collection on a
plane
right they all prefer a prime to r
because geometry because they all sit on
the on the same side of this line
and therefore they uh it's a legal
compromise where they all form a
collection of data
it's a slightly bigger collection and
everyone in that collection supports api
right
so that's one possibility and in fact
this argument
kind of works even if some of this
even if one of these agents also sits
right on this line
because what i can then do is to rotate
this line
very very slightly so that this point is
now
on on one side of on the same side of
this line at the a collision
and then i'm in this situation again and
then this small rotation always exists
because the number of points is fine
okay so that's one perspirative and
there's someone on the
right side of this line and that's the
possibility
there's all other agents on the other
side of this line
right then because i have at least three
collections i have at least
this means i have two colors on the
other side of this line
right and then kind of by the same
argument i can draw another separating
line i can find another proposal a very
close star but not quite at are
such that these these two collisions can
compromise over that proposed
right so by the same geometric
consideration they can now find a
compromise that would lead
that would enable these two collisions
to merge on this new compromise
right so either someone can join the
biggest coalition
or else the existing merge right so if
there are three coalitions left
there's still a compromise available
right so that's a contradiction
okay so you know in an orbit
okay so what do i need for this argument
to go through
right so this argument goes so as long
as
as i can find these proposals very close
to r
that agents can form compromises against
so this theorem holds so it certainly
holds if the proposal space is
all of our d it also holds if the
proposal space
is some then subset of rd so for
instance if it's qdr
and rd this argument still goes through
right i should just be able to pick
these points close enough to the point
of origin
however if my space of proposals is
sparse
which may indeed be the case in real
life so remember we are thinking of
these proposals as political positions
right and it may be very difficult for
you to articulate a policy proposal
that is somewhere halfway between uh
whatever
cafe should be open but dreams should
not be open
right so it would be difficult to
describe what the intermediate position
is
might say the number of available
positions is small right so this
argument no longer works
right so here's an example that sits in
r3
but the number of available proposals is
finite right so it's available for
proposals okay so this is the reality
status quo at zero
the proposals a b c d and b
that each proposal is currently
supported by two guys
right so there's v1 and v5 supporting a
there is v2 and v6 b6 supporting b
v 3 and v7 supporting c
v4 and v8 supporting d and there is one
agent v9 here supporting e
right and so they sit in these
collections so i have four collisions of
size two
one collision of size one right and they
say nice proposal p
over here right and that proportion
could potentially be supported by five
agents so five out of nine a majority
right but they can't get there by two
compromises
right because two if i just try to build
a two compromise between
say the kalishna and ae
v2 v6 right so i can't build a feasible
compromise around b
right because if just v5 and v6 were to
move there
right it would be just a collision of
size two nothing not an improvement over
the current stage
so i would really need in this case at
least three collisions
to form that compromise two-way
compromises are not enough
right so listen here if the proposal
space is dense two compromises
are sufficient and if agents are not as
sophisticated
at articulating complex proposals right
so
then they may need negotiations that
involve many more coalitions
okay so maybe a couple of words about
the convergence and speed of convergence
okay so i talk about these processes as
if they necessarily converge
right and that's because they actually
do right so the first simple claim
so maybe obvious to some people in this
audience well given the nature of this
audience
any sequence of single agent merge and
follow transitions
actually terminates liquidate number of
steps
so why is that well there's an easy
potential function
so let's define a potential function as
a sum of squares of collision sizes
right and then it's easy to see that our
rich
get richer kind of dynamics increases
this potential function at each step
right and this potential function has a
so the values it can take sit between 0
and n squared so that most tends to
create steps of my dynamics
right so that's easy now if i talk about
compromise transitions
write it slightly more complicated
because a compromise transition
so remember when agents break off from
two existing collisions
form a new one and leave parts of the
old collisions behind
so this may fail to increase this
particular potential function
but you can define a different potential
function kind of a lexicographic
potential function
that would actually increase at each
step
so convergence is still guaranteed so we
don't have a polynomial
so from this argument we don't have a
polynomial of bound on the speed of
convergence
so we can show that it terminates after
most well
n to the power n steps well it should
rather be eval
and those numbers so the number of
partitions but anyway
something that is super exponential
right and we don't
quite know if the normal number of steps
is enough
so we can strengthen this result
slightly so for this size out for
convergence in our d so this dramatic
argument
i showed you so i can claim that there's
a sequence of compromise transitions
that actually converges in a quadratic
number of steps
right and this is before because this
argument i showed you for three
collisions
so there was a merge transition or well
kind of a single agent transition a
single agent transition would be the
change of position
right so there were transitions there
that
increased so as long as the athlete
coalition is still present but there is
a transition there that increases this
quadratic potential function
so if you tell agents well as long as
there are three collisions
and you're not allowed to do general
compromises you are allowed
merge follow a single agent transitions
with the change of position
and once you run out of those and if you
are down to two collisions
right then you're allowed an arbitrary
compromise then
they are still able to converge the
majority supported outcome
and they're going to do so in quadratic
time right so this is kind of
encouraging with respect to convergence
okay so i think i have still three
minutes left and then there's half hour
for discussion right
that's the instructions i've been given
let me use these three minutes
to tell you about another metric space
but we only have very very preliminary
results
right and this is also very natural
metric space it's dehydrating
right so so potential proposal points
are points in zero one to the power d so
vertices of the hyper cube so they
related the status quo let's say it's a
zero point
so agent's ideal positions are also
vertices of the hypercube
right so what we know about this metric
space
is that compromises so two base
compromises may fail
right so that's actually a very easy
example maybe easy even than the example
i already
showed you right so suppose we have
five agents so agents are adults now so
there's a condition
here around this upper edge which
supports this proposal over here
right so both agents in that collision
prefer this point to zero
right so both so there's a pollution of
size 2 here
both agents in this function prefer this
point to zero
right and there's a single then here
right and there's no transition
in there's no transition here that that
would involve
just two collections however
there is a there is a collision among
three agents
uh that could potentially form if we
would allow three collisions to
negotiate
wait and this is this one right if you
look at these three agents
they could form a cholesterol this
bright yellow point
because they all prefer that to the
status quo
right so that would be a mature so this
bright yellow point would be a majority
supported proposal
but to get there they need negotiation
amongst three conditions
right so the question one can ask more
generally so what if they allow
compromise is allowing more than two
conditions right so suppose we allow as
many as t
collisions for something greater than
two right and
our our metric space is hyper g
so what the value of t would be
sufficient for convergence
right so what is the value of t that
guarantees convergence the majorities
to the most supported proposal in the
hybrid
and of course a trivial upper bound is
if you're low
okay so if you you can't have two
distinct collisions supporting the same
position because then they could
certainly emerge
right so merge transition is always
available right so the worst case is you
have a coalition
sitting at each point and some of these
collections could potentially compromise
so if you allow negotiations that uh
among as many as a number of vertices
minus one conditions because you don't
have a collision with zero
right then certainly kind of all agents
who support this most supported proposal
could just jump in one step and form a
coalition that proposed
and so that's enough about if you're low
negotiation between
negotiations among these many coalitions
you'll get to
you'll get the majority to support it
but this
seems like you know allowing too many
negotiators in the room
right so what you want to ask is can you
have like smaller negotiations
okay so we have some very partial
answers here
if you have three dimensions then it's
sufficient and necessary to have
negotiations among three coalitions
right so the example from the previous
slide showed that two is not enough
and we needed three to allow for at
least three collections to negotiate
right and it's not a very difficult to
show that three is actually sufficient
right and from that our conjecture for
some time was that it's sufficient to
set
to allow the collisions to negotiate so
if you are in dimension
d so then by allowing the collections to
negotiate you can always guarantee
success
right and then we try to prove it for
decal4 and as we are trying to prove it
we actually found the counter example
so for d equal four the answer is five
you may
need five negotiating collisions to get
to successful outcome
i can generally well i think the owners
tenses don't we don't know
so we have a lower bound which is kind
of like example from the previous slide
which says we need at least the
negotiating conditions we delete the
dimension
we have an upper bound that is a very
slight improvement over the trivial
upper bone
which is so we can improve it roughly by
a factor of two
which is very unimpressive i would say
right so the open question
is here is whether we can close this gap
right so whether we can somehow argue
that negotiations by smaller groups are
sufficient for convergence on the high
value
let's have further open questions so for
instance
kind of going back to rd so away from
hyper equipment back to rd
so all those simple transitions that
ensure convergence when proposals faces
a subset of party
so in particular can ask if the
compromises are sufficient
for arbitrary discrete subset authority
we don't know
right so or
kind of again thinking of rd so how rich
should the space
be for two compromised transitions to
succeed
right so we are so all d itself is
enough
q to the power d is enough so can we
still guarantee success for something
that is even smaller than q to the d
right or kind of at the more technical
level
in our d kind of we have this kind of
potential based
bound at on convergence
right which is exponential so can it
really be as bad as exponentially the
explicit sequence of compromised
transitions etc exponentially alone
right so we don't have an example so for
all we know maybe that just a bad proof
strategy and compromise transitions
over this converging polynomial thing
okay
so that's all i have for today so let me
stop here take questions
thanks thank you
um if you would like to ask a question
you can uh
you know simply unmute yourself and ask
or
if you are an attendee you can just
write something in the q a and then i
can
call upon you yes i have q a open so
feel free to start typing
um maybe in the meantime i can start
with a
question so your agents are very nice
because they're
always looking for a compromised
position is there a model of bargaining
you can add to this because
i might say that in order for me to move
from my current position to the new one
i need a certain payment
how would things change
right okay so that would give agents
more flexibility
right and so i would have to reason
somehow about
kind of the explicit utilities right so
okay so the short answer is i don't know
so what we try to think
a little bit is making the compromise
transitions more compromising
right because right now so i allow
agents from two collisions
c p prime c p and c prime p prime
to form a compromise around some p star
and this p star can be arbitrary
right so it doesn't have to be related
to p
and p prime so for instance it doesn't
have to be between p
and p prime in any sense right so it's
not unreasonable to require that this
compromise
actually sit somewhere between b and b
plane
right and then i'm not sure if our
argument goes through
i think our it's not clear to me how a
geometric argument will go through but i
didn't
really try to go through that but i
think that something one could explore
right so if buying compromises to be
actual compromises actual intermediate
positions
thank
are you other questions uh it is uh you
gave us
a lot of examples where uh under
different types of transitions and in
different metric spaces convergence did
not
there was no convergence this to me
seems to raise an algorithmic question
uh if you you have fixed your metric
space and you fix the type of transition
and you are given such an input and you
ask
does it converge have you addressed is
it a meaningful algorithmic question and
have you addressed it
yes i think that's a perfectly
reasonable question to ask
i think there is room for lots of pls
completeness results there
right which we haven't attempted to
prove but yes that's the sense i'm
getting
out of that right so proving kind of
arguing something about convergence
so may be difficult but yeah so indeed
the input
is a kind of succinct and discrete
object
so i have agents i have collections i
have
i have proposals and i'm asking what can
potentially happen in any sequence of
transitions
yes so i think it's an algorithmic
question that would be worth asking
is it a nice space or not are agents
going to
are agents going to converge are they
going to converge quickly what can they
potentially converge to
right so so generally throughout this
talk i just question
i just focused on the question of
whether they achieve majority supported
outcomes
right and not which of the majority
supported outcomes and in one of the
examples i gave
right so there were lots of them you can
ask
the question deciding deciding
convergence right
yeah right because there's deciding
convergence and there's deciding
if it's feasible to obtain convergence
towards a specific outcome
i'm sorry
can you repeat the answer please right
okay so
i'm just saying that there are two
algorithmic questions here right and one
is simply if agents are guaranteed to
converge to a majority supported outcome
a
majority supported outcome right and if
they're potentially if there's
potentially more than one
can they achieve convergence to a
specific one yeah
yeah thank you i think very interesting
right and no we haven't done anything on
that
and my suspicion is that the pls
kindness is how it's lurking there
thank you thank you
you wanna uh unmute yourself and just uh
ask your question
oh me yeah oh yeah sure
so i just wanted to know is it possible
that there could be an infinite sequence
of compromises
uh okay so i explained okay so forth
there
let me go back in my slides a little bit
okay so here i argue that every sequence
of two compromise transitions terminates
after the most exponential number of
steps
right and okay so i stated that for two
way compromises
but actually and i wasn't explicit about
that i'm sorry uh
the same argument and the same potential
function shows that
even if you're low multi-way compromises
uh you would still get termination of
that most into the power and steps
right so basically you get the sequence
of collision structures
and we argue that uh you can't repeat
collision structures
so you can think for kind of you you're
guaranteed convergence with this form of
compromises
so you can't repeat anything that you've
seen before
i got it thank you
are there any other questions
if not uh let's thank edith again and
yeah thank you very much for this uh
really nice talk and
uh next week we have javascript talking
about sub game perfect
equilibrium so until then uh thank you
for coming everybody thank you for idiot
for the talk
and we meet again next friday
thanks for having me thank you thank you
edith for the talk here